so for our agenda today I'm gonna cover
what is NLP how is NLP used out in the
worlds we're gonna dig into text
pre-processing some of the ways that we
clean our data in NLP and we're gonna
try some out we're also going to try out
a little bit of parsing we're gonna
cover a few of the more common language
models we're going to look at a bunch of
different applications within NLP and
we're going to visit some of the
challenges and considerations that arise
as we do NLP work and finally we'll have
a little bit of time for Q&A great so
what is NLP we're gonna start by
conducting a quick poll hold on
over to here so if everyone could go to
pull Evie calm / Marielle Frank
8:43 you can fill in some ideas on what
natural language processing is and we're
gonna actually develop a word cloud
using backwards
which is a language model within NLP
we're gonna get a little bit of a sense
using backup words what topics are
coming up the most so feel free to turn
and talk to the person sitting next to
you if you don't have someone sitting
next to you I highly recommend moving so
that you have someone sitting next to
you and feel free to talk it's okay
I'm gonna give you another prodigy 10-15
seconds so try to get your responses in
I already seen some themes pop up here
all right great so the biggest theme
that we're seeing is text which is very
very true to form text is usually what
we are processing and you can also move
from audio to text but ultimately we're
going to be processing text we see using
here extracting human because the
language that we're playing with is
human language data because the language
is in essence broken down into a data
format we see machines language I useful
analysis unstructured so that's an
interesting one understand and I'm
seeing inferring machines algorithms
great ok so are any of these surprising
to anyone does anyone
totally surprised by this probably not
the thing is what we're seeing here is a
word generated cloud using bag of words
which gives us a sense of topics um
so using NLP you were describing NLP I'm
gonna get back into slides you're going
to get back into full screen so what is
NLP NLP is a domain at the intersection
of linguistics artificial intelligence
and computer science with the goal of
enabling machines to interpret analyze
and generate natural human language so
you'll sometimes see natural language
understanding as well as natural
language generation both can fall within
the confines of NLP I I hope you really
got it to start in the 1950s originally
with Alan Turing at the famous
mathematician he developed this idea for
what should be really an artificial
intelligence and he hypothesized that a
computer would deserve to be called
intelligent if it could deceive a human
into believing that it was human so this
developed into the Turing test which was
used as a model for
meaning whether or not a program had
artificial intelligence for quite some
time almost around the same time the
1950s there was some machine translation
work that began to develop probably as a
result of the Cold War so that's really
where NLP was getting its start and
originally you know those two fields you
know using
trying to deceive humans into believing
something was human probably a chatbot
and machine translation we're using
different models but eventually the two
kind of came together into one fields so
how is NLP used and this is gonna be
another quick turn and talk I just want
to get a sense what are some ways that
you think you have used NLP today so
quickly chat with your buddy next to you
how have you been using NLP today
[Music]
there's a Lex accountant yeah absolutely
[Applause]
right so so I'm gonna pull up some
examples of NLP I want you to see did
any of these come up for you show of
hands alright who is use spellcheck or
autocorrect today it could be on your
phone it could be in a text document
you're creating who's used
auto-generated video captions at some
point today or seen them on YouTube
who's used a virtual assistant either an
Alexa or Google home today does anyone
know yeah has anyone used a search
engine
[Laughter]
what about autocomplete has anyone used
spam detection did you look at your
email today if so you were using spam
detection did you go onto a new site and
take a look at suggested articles that
also uses NLP there's a lot of different
applications within NLP or for NLP I
should say all right so now we're gonna
dig into the meat of it a little bit so
before you do pretty much any task
within NLP you're going to have to clean
your data this is probably true of most
data science so how do we do that in NLP
this really breaks down into three parts
so the first thing that we do usually is
noise removal so noise removal is where
you take everything out that you don't
want so this could be something like
punctuation this could be something like
if you don't want numbers in there this
could be something like if you want to
change all of your contractions into
full
from something like can't - you cannot
this is this is the stage where you just
get things out of there this is also
where if you've you know parsed
something or not parsed sorry if you've
scraped the web you've gotten something
from beautifulsoup
and it has a bunch of HTML in there
you're gonna be using probably URL up to
get rid of all of that noise there's
going to be HTML all over the place and
you don't really want to deal with that
that's not necessarily helpful for you
the next step is usually tokenization
and tokenization
has to do with breaking its text into
smaller chunks of text so a token is
either a word or some sort of freeze and
usually we we talk about words when
we're talking about tokens and this is
useful because a lot of the time when
we're trying to make sense of our texts
we're going to be developing a language
model which usually relies on breaking
text up into manageable pieces um so it
usually tokenization is either word
level or sentence level fortunately for
us
NL TK has anyone ever used an l TK by
the way show of hands
okay a few of you used NL TK it's the
natural language toolkit um and it's a
really common library within the domain
of NLP especially if you're using hype
on it
NL TK has a great tokenization function
you can either break things up by word
or by sentence next up you have
normalization so normalization is this
kind of bucket term that includes almost
everything else that you can possibly do
pre-processing wise this involves lower
casing and upper casing this involves
removing stop words stop words what are
stop words
um stop words are any words that we
don't really care about so these could
be words like love in on that don't
necessarily have much meaning now do we
have to remove stop words absolutely not
it's completely dependent on the context
of what you're doing with in NLP if you
are trying to generate text you
definitely don't want to remove stop
words this is actually probably going to
be important for you but depending on
their context you also might want to
remove even more language so you can
increase your number of stop words if
you're dealing with a particular topic
and you know that certain words are
gonna come up all the time and you don't
really care about those words and you're
looking for other themes next up we have
stemming and limitation so stemming and
limit ization are two ways of bringing
words down to their root form stemming
is a little bit faster it's also a
little bit more blunt it's not
necessarily going to look like real
words coming out but limit ization if it
takes into account what part of speech
the word is is a little bit more finely
tuned and it's able to really bring
words down to their root form so for
example um if you take the word was and
it's stemmed you're probably going to
end up with wha why is that
well stemming kind of generally assumes
that every word is a noun if it's not
sure so it just hacks off any any
endings that it can and it's like well
okay there's probably more than one wah
so it's a plural so let's just get rid
of that s well as if you have limited a
ssin what you'd really like to see is
was coming down to B so before we move
on I want to make sure everyone has
gotten a chance to pull up
[Music]
the repo that I had up at the beginning
[Music]
which if you haven't gotten a chance
please do now if you don't have things
set up locally you can use the binder
link right here and a jupiter notebook
will be opened up for you and we are
gonna dig into some pre-processing um by
show of hands who here has used jupiter
notebooks or something like it before
okay
almost everyone that's helpful cool so
if you have your notebook open you can
get into the pre-processing directory
and of course we have a server error
because why wouldn't we okay hang on one
second
I of course relied on the binder link
and now I don't have it open locally
okay so we're going into the
pre-processing directory and we're gonna
open up text pre-processing the note
book and we're gonna walk through what's
going on here these are a few different
ways that we can pre-process text so the
first thing we're gonna be doing is
importing the regex library for python
so does everyone have this open show of
hands thumbs up okay cool so first for
those of you who don't know Jupiter
notebooks Jupiter notebooks allows you
to run your code bit by bit
with little stop points so the first
thing we're gonna do is run this first
cell there's either a run button up here
or you can do I believe shift enter on
your computer and that should work too
so run that make sure you're able to
impor regex
and next up we're gonna import a few
different functions within NLT k
tokenize token isis word tokenize is
we're going to be tokenizing by word
we're gonna import the porter stemmer
and the word nut summer from NLT case
step module so let's run that make sure
that's working
everyone good so far Chopin's thumbs up
yeah absolutely
so in this case I'm just using the NLT
case summer as an example there are
other libraries that have summers as
well yeah I does anyone else have any
questions before we move on okay cool
next up we want to make sure that n LT K
is we have a few different corpora that
we want to import this is punked wordnet
and stop words so we're gonna go ahead
and download all of these oh yeah that's
a really good question I mean if I can
do that hold on
all right all right hopefully no one hit
a snag there what is he sorry that's a
really great question so corpora are
bodies of text so in the case of
something like stop words what you're
importing is a full list of stop words
that exist okay so next up what I have
here is a passage from through the
looking-glass I want you to turn and
talk to your buddy figure out another
text that you want to pre-process it
could be an email it could be something
from the news it could be from someone's
Twitter feed whatever just throw
something in there make sure that it's
longer than a single sentence you're
welcome to talk and for anyone unclear
make sure that the text is going between
the two triple quotes this is pythons
way of allowing you to do multi-line
strings
[Applause]
I'm gonna give you another five seconds
all right so we're gonna run this cell
and all we did here was we assigned that
string to a variable called text and now
we're gonna dig into the actual
pre-processing so the first thing we're
gonna be doing is some noise removal
we're gonna get rid of anything that
isn't a word words by the way do include
numbers digits are fine but it will get
rid of any punctuation in here so if I
do this I should expect to see all of
that sentence or not sentence sorry all
of that text without any punctuation
because I'm going to print it out
so here we go you can run the same for
your own text if you haven't yet already
[Music]
sorry that wasn't clear sure um so the
reason that we're doing a space is
because of in the case of some
punctuation it actually takes the place
of a space so we're just adding an extra
space in it shouldn't matter in terms of
once we get into tokenization sure yes
yeah absolutely all right so next up
we're going to be tokenizing we're gonna
be using the word tokenized function
from ltk so we're going to tokenize our
cleaned text and we're going to see
hopefully a list of words here and it
should be all of the words that were
included within the original text so
there we go so you can run your own cell
make sure that that looks all or in
order if you have any questions make
sure to ask sorry you just organized
using the space I yes yes
and next up we're going to be stemming
these words so we're instantiating the
porter some the porter stemmer from NLT
k we're going to create a list
comprehension and save it to the
variable stemmed where we're going to
stem each token that we've just created
within the tokenized list and then we're
going to print these out because we want
to see what these look like so go ahead
and do that for yours and take a look
and take a look with your buddy and chat
about it see what you see there see if
you see any surprises
[Music]
[Music]
all right was anyone surprised by
anything that they saw within their
stemmed text go ahead what was supposed
to do or else so what what stemming does
is it sort of lobs off prefixes and
ethic and apexes so it's it's just
trying to bluntly bring words down to
the root form it has no idea what part
of speech it is it has no knowledge of
the language specifically it's just
trying to do its best
uh yeah go ahead James O'Neill these
commissioners just stepping down I when
it stemmed it it leaves the oh and his
name is that an apostrophe after it's
because had this one big oh yes nice God
it changed it where it has ha ha yep it
has yep oh yeah now that's interesting
right go ahead
even the weird change the meaning of the
word so stealing I have a sale sale ing
so it probably thought stealing was a
verb and just loved off the ing I know I
saw some other hands go ahead hmm yep i
I think I saw some of their hands up I
don't know whether God Oh change your
into your
yeah seems like an important word for us
yeah yeah yeah um depending on the
purpose of what you're trying to do
stemming may not be the best choice but
it does do something that's a really
good question with an ltk I'm not sure
that you can I think with other
libraries that might be possible yeah
that's a really good question with a NLT
Kay there are there are other languages
that you can import I don't know how
much has been done so far with Chinese
specifically the the body that we're
working on right now is just for English
we can see whether it would it would
work for Chinese I encourage you to do
so but I haven't tested it out
personally
okay go ahead just briefly what would be
a scenario where this is actually
helpful um so this is helpful in certain
scenarios where if you're really if all
you're really trying to do is pull out
specific word topics like if you're
doing a back of word scenario and you're
just trying to pull out a few important
topics this will get you some of the way
there it might not be the most accurate
way but if you're trying to do something
quickly and you want to see something
all right so not necessarily we're full
sentences or we're your partner no no no
no you definitely would not want to be
doing anything where you care about full
sentences right yeah that's a really
good point
so like category if there's a thing
where somebody has to name categories
and you know you name it one way and I
name it a slightly different spelling
and I captured yes that we're trying to
say the same thing yeah
or British spelling versus English I
hope so yeah all right any other
questions before we move on great so
next up we're gonna try out some lemon
to zation so we're gonna try this out
with the word nut lemma tiser and the
lemma tiser we're going to limit eyes
every token again we're going back to
tokens we're not going from the stumped
text so we're going to be limit izing
those original tokens and we're going to
be comparing this to the stem text so
you can go ahead and run this cell and
you should see something slightly
different here it might still not be
great which might be a little bit of a
disappointment and that's okay and the
reason that this might be a little bit
of a disappointment is because at this
point we haven't passed in what the part
of speech is for each token so the lemma
tiser doesn't really know which token is
which part of speech so if we want to
make this a better limit ization process
what we're gonna have to do is pass in
both the token and its corresponding
part of speech so because n ltk is oh so
helpful it's part of speech tagger does
not work for this purpose so we had to
build our own part of speech get part of
speech function so I'm just gonna show
you what that looks like and the way
that we set this up we're what we're
basically doing is figuring out from a
the word nut corpus we're figuring out
how often a given token
is assigned as a synonym for all these
various terms so it could be if you if
you want to see whether something is
more likely an adjective or a noun you
can check whether or not it's usually
used whether it's synonyms are usually
used as adjectives or nouns so that's
basically what we're setting up here and
we're really paying attention only in
this case to nouns verbs adjectives and
adverbs but there's a much much larger
list of parts of speech that we could be
putting together but in this case this
is really what we're going to pay
attention to so if we go back into text
briefs pre-processing and we run this
we're just going to be importing that
function and now we're going to try
limit izing with the part of speech so
as you can see this is pretty much the
same as before but instead of only
passing in that token we're also going
to be passing in get part of speech
called on that token and we should see
the text limit eyes with part of speech
so this should look quite a bit better
so let's take a look and you're welcome
to do a quick turn and talk and observe
what did this do well what did this not
do well yes so limit izing is a more
finely tuned way of bringing words down
to its root form
so yeah in the case of seam seam is the
base form of seam number II yeah what is
the original lemma Thais are doing it
treats at this point it's treating every
word as a noun it's just defaulting to
the idea that every word is a noun are
you talking about seamed yeah so why in
this case is it seem so the original if
you look at the original tokens it was
seemed in the case of the stemmed text
it knew to lob off the edy right yeah
okay but in the case of the lemma Thais
text
it was treating this as though it were a
noun so it didn't know to lob off the
edy does that make sense
but once we passed in the part of speech
and it recognized that this was a bird
it was like oh okay
now we know this should have you know II
D is an ending for past tense so we can
take that off in order to get back to
the root form what's the benefit of
doing 8 um this was more for the purpose
of just showing you I mean first of all
if you happen to have a text it's all
just full of nouns if all you're really
paying attention to is a bunch of nouns
and this this works fine as is but if
you are paying attention to a text that
has more than just nouns you are gonna
want to pass in the part of speech into
natural language language processing one
processing remained processing and one
processing became the process ooh that's
really interesting yeah what was the one
that remain processing was capitalized
that could be lowercase yeah that's a
really good question and it would be
really interesting maybe if you ran
lower casing beforehand to see whether
that makes a difference
so next up we're gonna do a quick test
of stop words removal so the first thing
that we would do is import the stop
words corpus and we're gonna specify
that we're concerned with stop words in
English and we're gonna print these out
we just want to take a look at what
words we're dealing with here so you can
go ahead and run this and we see a whole
bunch of different words these were
really really common words that in the
case of a lot of texts wouldn't really
matter that much in terms of the actual
overall topic so if we see something
like into or through not necessarily
going to tell us very much if the topic
is murder mysteries if we're if we are
concerned with you know a poem where we
care about I you me things like that
then we probably wouldn't want to be
using this stop words list and we can
actually create our own but this
suffices for a lot of different contexts
so we can always use it go ahead I will
guess that I don't want to remove that
from the meaning of a sentence yeah so
it totally depends on what the context
is so this is really just going to be
for a situation where you are more
looking for overall topics okay if you
have this piece of work you can
basically just make your own dice sort
of like these of
yeah yeah you can you can make a list of
stop words from scratch which is
something that a lot of folks will do
when they're doing their own both both
for a bag of words and for tf-idf which
I don't know whether we're gonna have
time to cover a tf-idf but it's a sort
of inverted form of bag of words all
right does anyone else have any oh go
ahead do you know why there's just
single letters in the stop words single
letters yeah yeah so a lot of those are
from contractions yeah that's a really
good question
all right and we're just gonna run this
last cell and we're gonna see what our
original a list of tokens looks like if
we get rid of all of those stop words so
again this is going back to the tokens
this is not going to the lemma ties form
or the stem forms so you can go ahead
and run the cell and we should have a
little bit more of a sense of the actual
topics now from the text that we just
processed I does anyone have any
questions about text reprocessing before
we move on good all right fantastic I'm
going to jump back into the presentation
so you've gotten a chance to use both
regex and NLT kay here which is a really
good start you've actually done some NLP
know if you haven't before okay so next
step we're getting into parsing so
parsing is all about picking out
specific pieces of language that we want
to pay attention to so one of the things
that we often do with parsing is part of
speech tagging because we want to find
out find specific phrases that have a
particular grammatical pattern so we
might be interested in noun phrases we
might be interested in verb phrases we
might be interested in something where
you have a verb adjective or I'm sorry
verb adverb and noun or something like
that and we can use part of speech
tagging in order to specifically select
those chunks from our text but things
can get a little tricky right as you can
see here I saw how under a tree with
binoculars English is ambiguous and a
person a human can really figure out
them the most likely scenario in this
case is that it's the person who has the
binoculars but the computer can't so
that's that's been a challenge with in
natural language processing is being
able to figure out how to break these
chunks up in a meaningful way which
which is bribe grammar
I would say that this is a fairly
acceptable English sentence it's it
might not be the most clear sentence but
it is an acceptable English sentence and
there there is a lot of ambiguity if you
read headlines sometimes somebody will
write something in the most atrocious
way because it makes sense to them you
know as a native English speaker but
when they have it out there a bunch of
people will read it in a completely
different way and that's a common thing
that happens with just ambiguity in
general but the truth is usually we as
either native or just fluent speakers of
a language are able to determine okay
well this is the most likely scenario
but as I said unfortunately computers
are not there yet yeah at least usually
um another piece here is named entity
recognition or NER so a er is when we're
trying to find usually proper nouns or
we're trying to find special topics
within a sentence so usually you know if
something is capitalized at the
beginning we're going to say okay most
likely this is going to be a named
entity of some kind another interesting
topic within parsing is dependency
grammar so dependency grammar is where
we break language up into language trees
NL Tek and Spacey both are able to do
this to some degree Spacey's a little
bit better at this NL TK has a really
nice display function for it though and
that's something I'd actually really
like to show you so we're gonna go back
into
our Jupiter notebooks and we're gonna go
up a directory and into the parsing
directory and we're gonna open up the
dependency parsing notebook alright and
I'm crossing my fingers this is gonna
work because I've had issues with this
with Spacey importing here we'll see it
imports it imports beautifully locally
of course but we'll see what how it does
up here so what we're gonna do is we're
just going to create a little dependency
tree from a sentence that we add here so
first things first we're importing
Spacey and we're loading an English
corpus and we're gonna just call it when
we load it in we're gonna call it a
dependency parser so you can run the
cell and of course I get errors okay
can't find model I'm gonna try this
again you might need to in one second
I did I had to run that sorry this stuff
at the top - sorry the wet specie
download the specie download part
alright are you talking about this line
right here yeah three down this one yep
it just ran that sometimes likes to
throw errors we're gonna try this with
loading the Conda environment and see
whether this has
so they are saying poor webm from
spacing library yeah this this is more
of a jupiter notebooks slash binder
issue and less of a spacey specific
issue but for some reason NLT k never
has issues with so go figure okay
loading some stuff in apologies for the
technical difficulties um in the
meantime while this is loading if you're
able to run it please do
you can replace where it says my
sentence you can replace this sentence
with a new sentence and make sure it's
just a single sentence not 50 lines of
text all right I'm gonna try a slightly
different version of doing this kind of
import one second but in the meantime
work to get your own sentence here and
you're welcome to turn and talk to your
buddy to figure out a sentence that you
think would maybe be confusing for the
Machine or maybe you think it'll work
out really nicely for the machine
I suppose you had to do that for Mike
sorry al if you're able to get it
working just what to do your install
restarting the kernels yeah cuz that RT
was your once alright cool
seems to be working now alright
hopefully everyone has a sentence in
here now does anyone have an especially
awesome sentence that they would like to
share and I'll type it in here so we can
watch it live good alright I like to eat
apples and bananas throwing it in
all right we're gonna run that and now
we're gonna use the dependency parser to
parse out the sentence and we're going
to parse each word in the sentence and
we're going to learn a little bit more
about what is going on with that word
what the part of speech is whether
there's any other information that spacy
wants to tell us about it so we're just
going to do that first just to get a
sense of what we have here so we start
out with I it's it's a personal pronoun
tags it as P R P we have like a verb non
third-person singular present we have to
infinitival we eat as a verb it's a base
form apples it recognizes that it's a
plural noun and recognizes that it's a
conjunction
that's coordinating bananas is a again a
plural noun and it recognizes the
punctuation as a punctuation mark so we
have a period and it's a sentence closer
okay so from here we can see we can see
a little bit of what Spacey knows about
this sentence so next up we're gonna do
is we're going to import the NLT NLT hey
tree functionality which is going to
allow us to print out a dependency tree
from what Spacey has to offer so let's
run this cell and finally we're going to
print out this sentence as a little
dependency tree
so we'll see what it gives us so it's
recognizing that the sentence revolves
around like a dependency trees by the
way are not the same thing as all
sentence trees or grammar trees you're
going to see for dependency trees the
focus is always on the verb so I
connected to like eat is also connected
to like and then it recognizes that the
two part is connected to eat it's not
connected to I it's not connected to
like apples is connected to the eating
again not connected to the liking and we
have this connection this conjunction
here and then we have bananas so this is
just a kind of fun activity this isn't
necessarily something that you would be
doing as much with your NLP but this
gives you a sense of the underlying
understanding that your program is able
to develop about human language so we're
gonna move back into the slides and
we're gonna move on okay so language
models you're gonna be if you're staying
for the next tutorial session on NLP
you're going to be covering language
models I think fairly more in-depth than
what we have here so I just wanted to
give you a basic overview of some of the
language models that exist here so bag
of words is one of the most common it
again is what we used when we generated
that word cloud at the very beginning
for an understanding of what NLP is and
really what bag of words is doing is
exactly what this gif is explaining over
here it takes a bunch of words and spits
out the word counts and that's really
all it's doing it's a mapping of each
word to in number of times it appears
and you can do this as a vector you can
do this just as a dictionary like this
depending on what your use case is
backup words is also called the unigram
model because it is connected to
Ingram's so what are engrams engrams are
sort of an extension of what's happening
here so if you want to know how many
times for example and the appears you
would be able to figure that out using
an Engram model you can that would be by
the way of bigram model you can keep
extending by the way you can have a you
can have engrams going for an infinite
number of words in a row but at a
certain point you have less and less
information so it's helpful to kind of
play around with engrams and figure out
okay our trigrams the right way to go
are something slightly longer something
slightly shorter and from there you can
also make predictions about text and
this is where you can start getting into
text generation by the way because what
you can do is you can say so how often
does and the appear before bananas how
often does and the appear before apples
and from there you can start to figure
out a way of generating text so some
common libraries that you'll see for
both of these models these are by the
way statistical language models these
aren't getting into any kind of neural
networks or deep learning so some common
libraries are NL TK and scikit-learn
who here has used I can't learn before
pretty much everyone not too surprising
scikit-learn is great for data science
in general including NLP um so beyond
this there are a lot of other ways that
you can go with language models but in
essence language models kind of split
down into either statistical models or
neural language models and there are two
pretty common neural language models at
this point there are LS TM based models
LS TM stands
or long short-term memory models which
are a type of neural network that I'm
not gonna get into the annex is the
whole thing but if you google LS TM
you'll get a sense of all of what is
going on inside an LS TM cell but
they're actually very very helpful
models for making sense of language
there's also transformer models which
have been developed a little bit more
recently and the real advantage there is
LS TM models really only move
sequentially from beginning to end so it
can really only process language from
the beginning of a text to the end of a
text well as transformer models are able
to process in any direction which is
kind of cool so they have become more
and more frequently used if you've heard
of Burt if you've heard of Elmo those
are transformer models those are also
specifically pre-trained transformer
models that are getting a lot of
attention these days and funny I should
say attention because attention is one
of the big focal points of transformer
models I'm not gonna get into it right
now it's it's a hole deep rabbit hole
anyway you'll learn a lot more about
language models in the next tutorial
session so some applications so once we
have our text pre-processed maybe we've
done some parsing we've picked a
language model now we're ready to figure
out what do we actually want to be doing
so some common applications of NLP our
topic modeling text some similarity tech
similarity by the way it can break down
into not just something like spellcheck
you know you can figure out whether or
not a word is close enough to
misspelling but also something like
plagiarism detection
so there's there's a broad range of
topics even included within text
similarity you can also get into
sentiment classification and analysis so
you can try to figure out whether
reviews are positive or negative on
Amazon so Amazon definitely employs this
by the way this is this is something
that they care deeply about you can also
get into bias detection I've seen some
pretty interesting work done using
parsing to determine bias detection I'll
include that actually it's in the github
repo there's a bit on detecting gender
bias in Harry Potter
using parsing you can also get into
predictive text if you have a gmail
account it has probably already
converted to a point where it's
predicting your sentences this can be
kind of concerning this can be exciting
but it is a facet of NLP you can also
get into machine translation there's a
lot that's getting done there Google
Translate has made a lot of headway but
there's a lot more to be done and we can
get into topics of language
accessibility we can get into text to
speech speech to text and any kind of
video captioning closed captioning
anything that auto generates text based
on either audio or maybe even sign
language is helpful okay so what I have
here displayed is a an example of what's
called a word embedding which is
oftentimes really helpful with topic
modeling and is also helpful with text
similarity largely because we can talk
about text similarity beyond just the
you know whether or not a word
specifically looks like another word
or a piece of text looks like another
text but you can also get into is there
enough in common topically between two
texts so it's really cool about word
embeddings here like this this is where
Tyvek is you can say something like from
a mathematical standpoint King - man is
going to give you a queen which is
pretty like mind boggling but I highly
recommend looking this up later this is
pretty neat stuff that gets done all
right so moving on to some challenges
and considerations so with great
language processing comes great
responsibility I'm sure you've heard
this quote before there is a lot to
consider natural language processing has
a lot of applications it is everywhere
in our everyday of lives now you know
you remember when we were trying to come
up with all of the ways that we've used
natural language processing tools today
already and it's only 10:00 a.m. it
gives you a sense of how ubiquitous it's
become so because of that we really need
to pay attention to what we're creating
it is very easy to create accidental
biases through the model that we're
building or through our training data uh
who here remembers when there was that
Twitter bot named hey is everyone okay
so do you do you want to explain what
that was what happened yeah yeah
absolutely so what happened there was we
you know the Microsoft team thought oh
let's create this model we're going to
release it into the world
it's an unsupervised model of
machine learning and we're gonna put it
up on Twitter it'll learn how to
interact with people and become you know
more human-like and really ultimately
what happened was the data that it
started pulling in was really racist
really sexist really basically it
sounded like a giant troll so Microsoft
obviously didn't plan for this
but this is the kind of thing that
happens when you don't have control over
the training data and even if you do
have control over the training data you
have to be really conscientious about
what data you are feeding this model
there's some really amazing work also I
highly recommend if anyone has not read
Cathy O'Neill's weapons of mass
destruction that gets pretty deep into
why we really need to pay attention to
both the model and the training data we
also have to make ourselves aware of
privacy and transparency issues with in
NLP applications as we have Alexa and
Google home listening to us we have our
phones listening to us what you know
what does that mean for us
what does that mean for other citizens
or other people of the worlds so it's
something that we need to pay attention
to as we develop natural language
processing tools so another big facet
and this is more of a challenge is
language variation so language variation
exists not everyone speaks the same
English not everyone speaks the same
language even and people might even
speak varied versions of different
languages we speak different dialects we
speak different registers most tools
that we're developing in natural
language processing at this point are
built for and by English speakers so
there's going to be a bias there in
terms of what's available and it's not
necessarily going to generate tool
that are going to be useful across
different languages I actually just
spoke to someone at a conference a
couple of weeks ago who was telling me
about how in Latvia they had to recreate
an entire system for developing chat
BOTS because the English chat bot
systems that exists don't really apply
to Latvia so there's a lot I mean first
of all there's a lot to be done there
but of course that also means it's
really exciting because there's a lot to
be done there we can get deep into other
languages we can get deep into slang you
know if you if you're trying to
determine whether something is positive
or negative and you get slang involved
that becomes way more confusing for
varied computer models anyway there's a
lot of challenges and considerations
with in NLP I am actually going to leave
it up to questions at this point I
finished just a little bit under time
which I'm really excited about I was
nervous about going over does anyone
have any questions yes learning any data
Sciences focused on pre-processing
so I'm curious so that sometimes is done
at the noise removal step and you can
use very other models that already exist
in order to help you out with dealing
with misspellings one of the really
common ways that used to be done was
Levenstein distance if anyone's ever
heard of it which can be really helpful
a lot of spell check models rely on that
very domains which me sorry maybe maybe
I should bring this is the same process
used when you're looking at very
domain-specific language so like if you
are reading through a scientific paper
or you're looking at a document written
by someone that's very technical mm-hmm
those words aren't necessarily part of
most common models spell checkers for
that matter
would the same process I guess maybe
just lemon static yeah I mean Lebanon
and justice is one one way of tackling
that there are other models that exist
at this point there are you know certain
models like I know for example grammerly
employs deep learning in order to tackle
a lot of those issues but it it comes up
short sometimes for example one of my
colleagues at one point was talking
about palindromes and grammerly
suggested that they changed the word to
pun because palindrome is not a good
word to be using as is what Graham
relations suggested because you know
Graham really is being being a deep
learning model hadn't necessarily come
across the word palindrome frequently
enough yes
yeah yeah that's that's so it's gonna
depend on what my kind of model you want
to be using right so you can tweak that
as needed i and i'll TK actually has a
Levenstein distance function so you can
employ that if you want to check it out
but for example if you're trying to use
leaven shine distance for spell check
versus for plagiarism you're going to be
using different counts the catastrophic
sorry oh I am probably not the best
person to speak to you about that I the
folks so this tutorial is going to be
followed in this room by language models
tutorial and then I I think after that
by a deep learning one so I would say
speak to potentially the language models
folks but otherwise to the deep learning
folks about that any other questions go
ahead um so this is something that seems
to be going on a company by company
basis unfortunately it would be great if
there were you know a regulatory body of
some kind that said hey you need to pass
such and such criteria criteria in order
to really make this work but it's not
that doesn't exist yet unfortunately um
but I do know that for example Amazon
pulls a
it was I think a resume scanner that was
happening and they had developed some
sort of resume scanner using a machine
learning model and they were really
really excited about it but of course
the data that they fed it was from past
overall experiences that they had had
with previous candidates so they fed you
know a bunch of resumes and they said
you know these are the people who
ultimately got hired and stayed for X
number of years and these are the people
who quit pretty quickly or didn't you
know it didn't even make it past
interview rounds so the model wound up
favoring based on that training data of
course white men and specifically ones
who played a particular sport and went
to a particular college and it just was
not really what they had been hoping for
unfortunately but yeah that that does
factor into recruiting a lot any other
questions
all right we're all set anyone is
welcome to chat with me specifically
later I'm gonna probably be milling
around this room in this area all day so
thank you so much
[Applause]